foreign
talk about kubernetes I'm trying not to
spoil you desserts with yaml just yet
um so uh I want to show you some things
that on youtube.net but also I want to
explain some kubernetes to you the
reason is hi I'm Martin and I've
recently worked with kubernetes so I
work for a consultancy in Vienna the
consultmentation is based in Finland
called tier to every but over the last
years I've been working more and more
with kubernetes had to learn a lot of
things some things the hard way and I
want to share a bit of that with you so
to give you an easier way into
kubernetes so what I'll be doing is
giving you some overview over kubernetes
so maybe if you have not worked with it
before you understand some of the Core
Concepts
and we will be deploying things to a
live cluster so hope the demos will work
so we'll be deploying a.net app later
and spring it up in a real cluster
also I want to talk a bit about how you
can package your
final applications in our case we ship
some Helm charts I'll explain that later
to customers so we package things that
customers can install on their own
clusters
um why we've been doing that so we've
seen a few different needs so some
customers come to us and say yeah we're
using kubernetes if you want to write
software for us
um if you if you want to be paid you
need to ship it in a way that's able to
run in kubernetes
um others want to move to the cloud
but don't want to avoid or want to avoid
vendor locking
so in at least the german-speaking area
customers are still a bit afraid of the
cloud either for legal reasons for
political reasons whatever
and so we also see a lot of mixed with
with hybrid environments where people
want to run things on premises or in the
cloud and want to use kind of basically
the same way of packaging duplication
that works in both instances and
kubernetes really helps here
um
also we've worked with a
companies that had run their factories
that produce goods and they have
on-premise kubernetes classes as well
so
um
we've been working with them and
we had a look at okay we need to do
something with kubernetes what are the
tools that are available to us
and then once you look up the chart
it's really hard to to like navigate all
the different concepts and components so
I hope it can give you an easy
introduction if you're new to that
one thing is the terminology so
everything is based around shipping
things so we have very nautical
terminology
um those of us who have been to the boat
yesterday may have used some of them or
seen some of them so we're shipping
containers
from docs with docker and also the name
kubernetes is from the Greek word
kubernetes which just means pilot or
hampsman
and all the other tools you will see
will usually have some reference to some
knowledgeable terminology
so when we think of
shipping and application or making sure
that an application runs in production
we usually have some different
components involved in there we usually
have some operating system candle we
have some operating system around the
kernel in Windows that's usually
kind of intertwined with Linux it's a
bit more open
we have some form of application servers
so for example if we're developing an
angular application that might just be
some nginx web server Apache web server
whatever with our stuff on the top so
usually we write the stuff on the top
and then figure out how to deploy the
thing into production
and the first time we do this we usually
create an installation document
and that is hopefully up to date two
years later as well
yeah I hate writing documentation
so how does this look when you move to
Containers so in containers we basically
package everything that is not the
kernel and pack it into one shippable
unit
and we only need to take care about that
so we don't no longer need to explain to
operations people how nginx needs to be
configured where these files need to be
placed it's already pre-built
so the installation document goes away
yeah I have to write less documentation
I like that but actually I do write
documentation it's just it has become
code it has become the instruction on
how to actually build that container
so instead of some PDF with some prose
words we can just write code
all the steps that are needed to
generate the container that is then able
to run
and
the way this works is we basically share
the operating system so traditionally I
don't think anyone still does that but
actually I once worked with Public
Safety infrastructure but it had to be
done just work on Bare Bones we usually
use some hypervisors some virtual
machines
but we no longer need to manage the
virtual machines we just need to manage
containers that run on some shared
operating system by the way if you're
designing such systems a container is a
very good isolation boundary it is not a
security boundary so you're sharing the
kernel you're sharing resources if you
need to design an architecture
do not consider container boundaries as
security boundaries that's also why you
will see for example with Windows
containers options like hyper-v
isolation for containers where they
actually spin up a new candle instance
just for your container
but of course you're writing usually
more complex applications right if
we spent two years developing a large
system with 20 30 40 people so whatever
those implications become quite complex
over time and you need to figure things
out like how do you communicate between
containers how do you do I do the
configuration management it's usually
more than one instance it's running I'd
like to
we did have to work in kind of a
resilient way run across multiple hosts
then I need to do a load balancing I
need to figure out how to configure my
different services and so on usually I
also want to have zero downtime
deployments so deploying an update and
everything should still be running
traditionally
there might be some problems with that
especially when you're dealing with
Legacy software that you need to lift
and shift into kubernetes but at least
you get some tools with that that's
basically called orchestration
there are very few other options but
kubernetes just came along and killed
everyone else so the momentum behind
kubernetes is just enormous so it's
more and more companies publish how to
use it it's more
even seen in public companies that used
to operate their own data centers and
yeah now we're not doing anything new
and that changed over the last two or
three years even in Austria
and how you benefit is those platforms
orchestration platforms help you with a
lot of the cross-cutting concerns so
when you do some diplomacy do operations
there's things you need to think about
like logging how you configure your
application how to do deployments how
these things find each other
as well as how you do some diagnostic
work if you need to figure out how
certain bugs happened and how you
reproduce them
and also
there are more things up there but at
least the platform kubernetes can help
you with some of them so for example you
can even have kubernetes
figure out how you reach some other
service that you need but even the
things on top of that so like dealing
with different communication protocols
or some Frameworks that help you
implement microservice architectures
those will usually be easier to do once
you run a kubernetes because there are
tools and and Frameworks based on
kubernetes that will help you tackle
these as well
and kubernetes comes in a lot of flavors
so if you Google thinks okay I need to
set up a local kubernetes cluster for
development maybe we cannot do it in the
cloud because of legal reasons
for example if you're working with some
infrastructure provider that works in
critical infrastructure
and you look at how this has been and I
think it's built kind of similar to
Linux where you have basically an open
source core that you could use on its
own but it's quite difficult to do
so you could download all the components
it's go source code you can compile it
and you can run it but it's very
difficult to configure so usually it
will use some form of distribution
um can be something like Suzy Rancho
kubernetes engine can be read at
openshift or the OSS variant okd
and that is usually easier to to install
on premises
but if you go to the cloud you will
usually use some kind of managed service
like Azure eks
you can use a Google kubernetes engine
Amazon has an offering as well and even
on
local hosting companies you will usually
have some form of managed kubernetes
platform as well
and speaking of these components you
will usually see two types of components
one of the like control plane components
that do all the intelligent work and
then there's the things that just runs
on your worker nodes
so
um I just wanted to highlight two of
these in the
and it doesn't work
so basically the thing that you interact
with will be the API server
that's what you just interact with when
you deploy something when you ask
kubernetes hey what's the status of
something that's the thing you interact
with
and then there's a database in it
basically I usually explain kubernetes
it's a database of configuration and
things around it that make it work as
you configure it
if you use managed service
usually those control plane services
will be managed by the cloud vendor and
we only manage and pay which machines or
which worker nodes you need to run
so I would have something like Azure AKs
where just to find okay there are
certain pools of Agents maybe with
different sizes I can mix and match
mixed Linux nodes and windows pools and
just configure how many I want and pay
for them
so it's quite it's it's become quite
easy to set up kubernetes in cloud
services right now
so
how does kubernetes benefit me
so everything in kubernetes is basically
abstractions or abstracts or
abstractions
so you have some application needs that
might be networking so you have two
containers to need to talk to each other
it could tell kubernetes we want to talk
to each other and whatever your
networking infrastructure might be
could have some on-premise Cisco
networking you could have some Azure
v-nets that will just work without using
application developer or
most of the times even operations guy
need to think about
you can also say okay my application
needs storage like I need to persist on
PDF files that people can upload and
whatever platform you run on that
storage will be provided for you so you
don't need to think about like mounting
Azure disks or using elastic block
storage you can just say yeah I need
this directory to be in persistent
storage with maybe a few options
like how fast should it be how much
space to anticipate Etc
same goes for load balancing so
different clouds have different
infrastructure different on-premise
systems can have different like Cisco
load balances for example
um you just say yeah
um these instances of this service that
needs to be reachable via the public
internet and load balanced please make
that work and in Azure if you use AKs
that will for example be an Azure load
balancer
and there are some other things as apart
from infrastructure so you can have some
you can have some configuration that can
be just like key value pairs or you can
have secrets that you would usually use
for things like data bus passwords or
default application passwords
also don't forget you're running on the
platform that implements scheduling
so you can also make use of that and do
things like Chrome jobs in the thing
that already implemented scheduling
across a distributed system so don't
forget that your platform can also help
you with your basic in-app abstractions
so for example if I had three hosts that
were small kubernetes cluster
I have an application with a web server
some API component maybe and a database
server
what happens if I deploy that it
kubernetes would try to distribute my
workloads
and then the postgres service said yeah
I also need some persistent storage
so this storage would be provisioned it
would mount it and it would make sure
the platform would make sure that um
this persistent storage is available at
the directory that the postgres expects
and if that host host goes offline
that workload will just be rescheduled
on a different host
again persistent storage is persistent
it's just mounted to another host
without any operate intervention
if I then try to scale up my application
maybe have three instances of my service
running it would just spin up more
services and if I then wanted to update
to a newer version so the green one up
there the default would be rolling
update so it would just spin up new
instances and kill the old ones
continuously
the way we usually split up or divide
the cluster is using namespaces so we
can have different
virtual clusters or virtual views of
clusters
to separate our applications these can
be like different applications that need
to be deployed on the same cluster you
could also use production and staging
environments and make sure that you
don't run into any like CPU and memory
resource conflicts with that
and you could have two instances of the
same application running on the cluster
this is also a good boundary to separate
like um which users have access to which
name spaces so if you're using
um
any access control system that's also a
good way of separating a cluster
especially if you run things like
openshift over maybe a thousand nodes on
premises there's usually
some Access Control implemented so you
will have your own virtual view over the
namespaces that you have access to
no
let's look at the different components
and to apply something
so the smallest unit in kubernetes is
called a pod
so when you work with tools like Docker
you would create a container
and that would be the smallest instance
in Docker the smallest instance in
kubernetes is basically a pod so you use
the port to run a container
you can actually also run multiple
containers in there
um
that's usually used for additional
things like logging proxying Etc
um but every part gets its own IP
address
it can communicate with other pods with
the other possibly addresses it will
have networking setup and it will have
persistent storage setup so for example
for example you could have a part that
has a container with a web server and a
container with some synchronization
service it just synchronizes some local
volume
that would be the smallest smallest
thing you can deploy
how you would do that is
by using yaml so I've set up a
small cluster in azure
in Europe so I hope it works
and
the main thing about kubernetes is it's
all the amplifiers so much the amplifies
to become sentient
basically and you usually have these
things that you deploy with some API
version and kind so this is a part that
I want to deploy a metadata usually
specifies the name and or the namespace
where it goes
in this case I am in a demo namespace
and then you just Define yeah which
containers should go in the port
there are other things as well you can
set but one of the most important things
is resources
now the important thing is of course uh
which image I want to deploy so give a
name and an image so for example I want
to deploy the business books image I can
specify some command that needs to run
but I can also specify the resources
that's important mostly for scheduling
so for example you say I need it around
was 100 m it's a milli CPU so it's 0.1
CPUs
that should be free on that node so that
the scheduler would schedule the
workload on that node you can also
specify some limits so if you use more
than that you can set an higher limit to
just the light to to
um have some more available during Peak
load
so what I do here I uh
run a shell command in a pcbox container
that just print something and then
sleeps for 10 seconds so
how do I interact with my clusters so on
the command line we have Cube CTL
Cube cuddle usually for the rest of this
demo I have a breeded that with KC so
um I have more screen estate available
and it can apply this yaml file
I can also use this KC get po is short
reports command now if I'm executing
that it will say oh it's running perfect
so I've been able to deploy something
but you notice there is a sleep command
so it just finished and now it's running
again the reason it's doing that is
kubernetes actually figures out yeah I
defined that some something should be
running so if it stops I need to restart
it and that's what it should do whenever
it it stops or crashes
foreign we can also have a look at
the output
using cubesatl logs
and I should see the output of the last
run instance
after some time it should also try to do
some back off
so if the applications fails all the
time you will also see the state crash
loop back off so it will wait a bit
until it tries to restart that can be up
to minutes
so let's delete it again and Casey
delete
perfect
and the abstraction over that seems I
don't want to
create 500 yaml files if I want to just
deploy 50 instances of 10 services
I want to basically have an abstraction
over that as well and that is called
deployments so you don't need to think
about the individual Parts you just say
hey I need to have three parts that kind
of look like that so you give it a
template we specify how many of them you
want to have run
and what the abstraction also does is
when you do some changes to that
configuration basically you want to
deploy an update or a change that will
also take care of things like rolling
updates so you can specify like how many
things do you want to have offline at a
given time and it will do that for you
let's have a look
let's watch deployments and pods
so that yaml file is a bit larger
so it's no longer a pod it's a
deployment
it also has a name
and then it is a specification and now
it gets a little bit more complicated so
I set a deployment is based on some Port
template so you will see there is a
template entrance entry here and that's
basically the same I would have in the
podium file so I have more metadata and
I also have a specification
so you will see us back a lot of times
in the amplifies and you just need to
mentally keep track of where you are
that's one of the difficult things about
the dcml files in this case this is now
a pod specification and that should look
quite similar to what we have done in
the past
we specify which image
to run we specify some resources and in
this case it's also a web server and we
want to tell kubernetes here you know
what this service has something running
on Port 80 that's interesting maybe you
want to use it later on somewhere else
we could also use this to to Define some
alliances but this is standard HTTP that
works with all the defaults in the
platform
so what's this this is we are able to
specify some additional metadata on
basically everything one of them being
labels I can apply labels to pods I can
apply labels to deployments and that's
used to find things later on
in this case
[Music]
a deployment is basically a
Reconciliation Loop so every so often
the system will look at okay which parts
are running
which deployments exist and then it says
okay there is a deployment so it says I
want to have two instances running
with a selector that says I want to have
two instances of running matching this
definition
and it if it doesn't find two of them it
will deploy them using this template
so that's the way to think about these
selected definitions
so selectors are usually used to find
pods and then the reconciliation Loop
will see okay what do I need to change
in the system
and that's basically how most of the
things in kubernetes work
so let me just deploy that one
and we see we have this deployment now
it says rated two of two and we can see
there are two parts in here those also
get some uh random name
so we have two distant parts
and they should be running so what
happens if I do some changes
let's maybe change that to three
so it just spun up another instance
um
if we lift and shift existing things to
kubernetes
sometimes we are not able to have
rolling updates working especially with
database updates sometimes you need to
do something different
if you really really need that there is
a way to do that using a different
deployment strategy so you can change
that for example to recreate
so if I deploy a new instance if I
changed image there's a newer version of
Alpine available
it would restart all the containers at
once so your system would be offline
yeah now it doesn't find the image
because I think
23 should be the next one so you see
there is an error image pool
and now change let's change back to the
default configuration
so the default should be rolling updates
you see there are now four instances
scheduled
so they are containers where creative is
creating While others were terminating
so we had now a rolling rolling
deployment
yeah I just deployed an HTTP server how
they reach that
one of them would be to use port
forwards so for example if I use this
vs code kubernetes plugin I can see it
as deployment there are the pods and I
can actually
set up a port forward
maybe local port 8080 to
one of the parts of the deployment to
Port 80
so there's the cubicle port forward
command I don't like to type that
manually
so let's see localhost
it works perfect
so
um next to deployments there's also a
different way to deploy parts that would
be stateful sets so you've seen these
parts have some random identifier there
are situations where you don't want that
usually these will be stateful
applications like databases or Cache
clusters and they really rely on some
stable naming so for example cash
instance one cache instance two cache
instance three and because when you
deploy new parts the cluster needs
usually needs to know hey did node
server recover again or did I add a new
node to the cluster and so this is
usually fixed by using stateful sets
um those also do not do rolling updates
they just restart one instance after
another in contrast to the deployment do
we just see that just restarted
everything at once
and
um usually that they also have some
additional methods to have different
persistent storage for each instance but
typically you would only see that in in
like pre-existing software that you
deploy to your clusters that is like a
database or a cache or something else
but what you will need is there a way to
for these services to talk to one
another so I could find out which pods
are running what IPS they have in the
cluster and talk to them by IP address
if I run some containers but finding
these IP address is kind of hard and
that's what services are for
so in kubernetes you your typical way of
resolving other services would be DNS
and services help you set up the DNS
so you can provide a single endpoint for
things to connect to the instances of
your ports there are a few different
types the default one is cluster RP
so every service could have one IP
address that you just use so you don't
need to think about something like
re making sure that you do DNS queries
all the time and you don't end up with
daily and as address so you just have
one IP and that IP will be load balanced
to some instances of the of the
application that are running
so that makes it a bit easier to think
about these uh
ways of resolving other other things
so if you also want to make things
available outside of the cluster
uh you can also use services for that so
you can for example deploy notepad note
Port service that will still have an
internal IP but for example it will make
a the service available on all the
worker nodes on a specific pod so for
example if you're deploying on-premise
systems you maybe have some mqt or mqtt
messaging system you can just say hey
Xpose Port something on all nodes and
forward it to that instance and and that
would work quite well
in a in an um Cloud environment you
would usually use a load balancer
service if you want to make things
available uh to the public that would
usually provision a new IP address or
configure an existing load balancer to
also have some rules to balance to your
instances
so let's try and deploy some services
foreign
so service again
client service some metadata with a name
this
for this one I want to deploy class
Therapy Services which is basically the
default
and again I specify selector so I say
okay which parts do I want to Target
again with this uh labels that I want to
query and what ports do you want to
expose
so you see there is a new service
created
it has a new different uip address and
now every component in the cluster could
just use this IP address to talk to our
services or resolve it via DNS so just
to test that I have some parts that
runs a BusyBox instance
so
and a good way of now running things
into classes I can just execute
something in the in a an existing
container
so I want to have an interactive
terminal
to my busy box
container and I want to run a shell
perfect
so I could do curl http
this IP address
kind of doesn't work in here
then use
whatever you get
and I get this nginx HTML page but of
course I hit appear dresses
so you can just use the name of the
service
and that should work
um if you deploy things in different
namespaces
the full name would be demo front end
dot demo that's the current namespace
name if you need to talk to things in
different name spaces you can use
the other
DNS components for that in theory the
fully assisted as we see
Caster local but your default search
domains should resolve everything fine
with sales name Dot namespace
Okay so
let's try something else let's see say I
want to make this publicly available
so I can deploy another service
this time I switched class type P to
load balancer
so you see load balancer and then
external IP pending
and what pending means is is in Azure it
will provision a new IP address and
configure Azure load balancer for that
so I got some IP address
now let me check that
maybe not yet
takes a bit
so in in Azure we usually have that
fancy interface so like here is a
kubernetes cluster you can change things
in the background this will actually
create a new Resource Group
with all the things in there so my node
pools will become virtual machine skill
sets
and in there I should also see public IP
addresses and the load balancer so by
just deploying some yaml file Azure
nodes or AKs knows how to do that with
the Azure load balancer and the Azure
way of implementing infrastructure I
could use exactly the same yaml file
deployed to Amazon it would work the
same just with with the different
platform components
so I should see front-end RP
configurations
and the
inbound rules so
yep now it works I have my web server
however
that might not be the
easiest way to manage exposing HTTP
Based Services there's also an
abstraction called ingresses
and the ingresses you use to define how
HTTP cluster from outside the HTTP
traffic from outside the cluster is
routed to components running in the
cluster
so it is basically and layer 7 load
balancer actually a reverse proxy
and the way you use it is you say on
this host name maybe with that path
routed to a specific service
and this is the first one that
kubernetes actually doesn't Implement
itself so you need to bring your own
component that then implements that
abstraction
so I could install nginx I could install
AJ proxy traffic Etc
there are some custom plugins as well if
you need to integrate maybe an external
thing like
it's basically load balancer
that could also integrate with that
abstraction so again that's the
interface you use an application
developer specify
what
URL what path goes to which service and
then in turn it will route to the to the
correct Port but
you could also do some
advanced stuff with that so that can
redeployments specifying which traffic
for which users should go where your
rewriting is quite good if you have like
subpaths but your application doesn't
understand subpath you can just rewrite
rewrite that and one of the most
important things is usually TLS of
loading so you would configure your TLS
certificate on the Ingress
or you have a component that creates TLS
certificates for you using things like
let's encrypt
but you can also specify course headers
in there which is quite useful
and you could even do some
authentication stuff like make sure that
for example there should be a bearer
token in every request to your API
so
let's have a look at that
so ingresses next type of record
metadata and the specification
what recently changing kubernetes over
the last years is
you should specify an Ingress class that
should be available in your cluster
usually when you deploy all these things
that you could use to actually do the
reverse processing they will provide an
English class name that you can use in
your English definitions so for example
I want to work with the nginx system
that I already deployed to the cluster
and I just Define some rules for example
demo cluster does model 80
everything under root should go to set
to the cells I just deployed at Port 80.
So currently
there should be nothing running on there
so I'm reaching the Ingress controller
basically the engine X instance that is
looking at the ingresses in the castle
but it doesn't find anything
so if I
deploy this Ingress
yeah
that is deploy it
it should find
the correct nginx instance
what it can also do in there is
currently
cached in a real wave
is
also specify TLS configuration so once
you specify TLS it will look
at some secrets that is also a
kubernetes object that can contain
either unstructured key value pairs or
TLS certificates
and find the correct certificate for the
host teams in my case I also use a
component called set manager that are
already deployed and configured in the
cluster that uses let's encrypt to
create these certificate so another
thing I can have in that metadata apart
from labels are annotations which is
basically additional information
for other components looking at that
definition so
I gave you this certificate issue
configuration that's valid for a whole
cluster for let's encrypt just use that
and if this secret doesn't exist request
a certificate
and that's also
why this https is already working
so
um something I will show you in a bit
you can also have contract map secrets
you can also have yaml files for
defining how you want to do storage uh
what kind of persistent volumes you want
to have and what's also quite useful in
a lot of Enterprise applications you can
run jobs
so you can do something like match
processing where you can use the API
service to schedule a job maybe if you
want if someone clicks an export button
and you need to maybe generate an export
you can write code that actually submits
the correct yaml file or the correct
definition to have your job running
maybe for that one export you can also
Define Crone drops so for example if I
want to generate some reports or remove
some stable data every hour I could also
make use of that platform again Chrome
shops just an abstraction overdrops
so let's have a look at an actual
application
so I created a
angular front and end.net backend
application
I'm going to spare you the details just
saying the front-end this build using a
Docker file you may have done it before
backend application actually is now
based in written in.net
7.7 will have a new feature for
publishing containers
so what you can do in in.net7
is
you can use a published profile
called default container
you specify which operating system and
architecture you want to run on and it
will just create that that container for
you
so
and it actually doesn't use a Docker
file it just uses an API to communicate
with Docker to just say okay these
layers are the base layers just add
those files that I just created so you
don't need to go through a docker-based
build to get your container
yep and it now published
this image I could also specify
something like
and it would publish the same thing with
with a different version
so if you have trouble maintaining
Docker files to to do your.net builds
this is probably going to help you I
think you can even do it with console
applications
and use it's not directly
but okay yeah it's brought in in this
case by the SDK are depending on what
type of project you're using might need
to reference a specific nougat package
you will find that in the dotnet
documentation once.net Sam is released
there's been a few changes to that okay
let's deploy something
I'm just switching namespaces
nope
okay now there are more things in here
let's just start with a few things
already
so in this case I need a database
this is a bit much to deployed once so
of course I can use the same file for
moderate BML files in this case
I deployed a secret
this is basically also deploying key
value pairs of names and values in this
case there are base64 encoded
I also Define a persistent volume claim
that means hey I want some persistent
volume to be available
saying yeah I want one gigabyte and then
Azure has this storage class
which gives me faster Azure disks
and a deployment
that references
the secret to Define an environment
variable so you can define environment
variables referencing Secrets contract
Maps or just putting values in inline
and it also
mounts the volume or it makes the
persistent volume available to the pod
and test the container where to mount it
inside the container so this should be
deploying a postgres database
it should be ready by now
I want to have
my front end running
I've also created a
service footed front and it looks just
the same as the ones I showed you before
backend is a bit different in this case
I am using asp.net configuration system
and maybe I don't want to hard code all
the values either in duplication or in
the deployment
so I can use something called a conflict
map that also stores key value pairs in
this case I'm
will be making that available via
environment variables and what you need
to do in kubernetes is you need to use
double underscores and the asp.net
configuration system will understand
these double underscores as well
um it's just kubernetes doesn't allow
single underscores in environment
variables
so
deploy the configuration
[Music]
now to the deployment so here at the I
defined the container
I'm referencing my custom image
and I'm setting environment variables so
I'm setting some inline
and then I'm also telling it hey just
everything that's defined in that config
map
just dump it into the environment
variables
so that's a very lazy way to do things
but it works
so I also want
a service
for that
and now the important part
I want to have an Ingress so different
you might have done before is yes I
still want everything under the slash
path to go to my front end but
everything under slash API I want to
send to my backend
so I don't need to worry about cores
having like a different domain it's just
on the same domain the reverse proxy
will just sort out which requesters and
to which
um to which basically service
so let's see that should be running
okay
that persistent volume was still there
now let's look in
luckily the password is written here
Ander should be able to
create new items
perfect so now I have a running
application
how do I deploy that so we've seen we've
had a lot of vml files so far I needed
to deploy what was it six ml files to
just get a small application running and
the more complex your application gets
the more yaml fights you have you're
just throwing amplifies together until
the sentient and the way Helen works
is you define a chart basically a map
the things you want to have in the
application in a bit of an again another
layer of abstraction so it's basically a
template on how to create those objects
so if I want to have an application I
can package it as a Helm chart and the
heat these are the knobs you can turn
those are the contract values that we
support and then you render out all
these definitions
so these are go templates it's a
template cooking language that might be
a bit weird the first time if you have
not yet used go
you usually Define a default values file
which is also just the yaml file that
with your own schema
and you allow users to customize some of
these values so you will have an
override that is just merged
and then you can use your template to
use the values in there to render your
definitions
also we've understand that you can
package that you can ship it to
registries you can let other people use
that and you can even use pre-built and
charts so
just a quick
demo
how would that look if I actually use
hem charts so for example
let's say I want to install WordPress on
myself
that would mean I could add a repository
in this case a bit numb is a company
that publishes a lot of Helm charts
I can update the things that are in
there so it just knows it downloads the
index and knows which packages there are
I've already done that so that would be
an error now
yeah and now have the
WordPress namespace
now I want to not use the default
password since it will be available
publicly so I've created a secret
definition
and the way many hum shots work is
you can Define values and you could
Define values in line but that means
they are no longer in this secret system
where it might be encrypted in the back
end
so usually reference existing stuff as
well in handshots so in this case these
are some content values that I can
change in the helm chart so you can
change something like the username
I can change the service types I can
enable ingresses and Define the things I
will specify about these ingresses so
amount of TLS I needed this specific
annotation for search manager to issue
the correct certificate and the hostname
and the way to install that
is to use Helm install with a release
name which chart to use which names list
to use and my override values
so
it's now slowly coming up
it deployed a
database
that might take a few seconds to spin up
so there's just a lot of things going on
there
reading
I can also have a look at that via some
uis so for example I like to use a
Rancher which can actually manage or
connect to multiple clusters
have a look at the workloads in the
WordPress namespace prefix those things
are deploying and I can also look at
storage so there should now be
persistent volumes in here
so something for the Mario DB
created 50 seconds ago
yeah the database seems to be running
now WordPress should be starting in a
moment yep
and here we are
so like successfully deployed
I'm not going to log in now I hope you
trust me that that kind of works
but usually you want to create your own
Health charts
so you can use commands that head and
create Foo which would create a new
basically empty chart there's already a
lot of the structure you will need in
there so for example a default yaml file
some templates that will help you set up
sensible defaults so for example like a
deployment and then there's a lot of
templating thing going on in there
I've already created that
for the to-do list
already exists
so in my to-do list demo
I also
have this values file
maybe some different defaults
and my own template so for example
in the interest there I can use some
variables so that language is a bit more
complex I suggest looking at some
examples looking at some in GitHub and
looking at the documentation
you will find a lot of things like this
include statements or template
statements I use things of a template
file you can also have some logic there
like if else if I specified an override
value do something with data or it just
yeah uh play with this little
that's the most I can say in the
remaining 10 minutes
but it usually makes it easier to to
um make things configurable so whenever
you want to specify some concrete value
in the ml file you would usually
reference the values that have been
provided to the helm release
so
let's just
try to deploy that
help install
test instance
then I need to specify the health chart
that's not just a directory
to-do list and I have some
overwrite values here
and that should deploy different
instances
all right
because I'm not gonna wait for that to
be fully deployed
let's just have a look at some other
things so I already mentioned if you're
configuring with.net
environment variables work by default
you can use double underscores to set
them
you can awesome Mount things as files so
if you have conflict maps or Secrets if
they're Json format it is very easy to
just Mount them as files so you can
mount not just persistent volumes but
also you can use your secret as a volume
reference the Json file in the
configuration Builder
with database migrations I usually
suggest
trying to deploy as often as you can and
make sure your deployments are backwards
and forwards compatible it doesn't work
all the time maybe you need to fall back
to this recreate deployment strategy
or you have something like a knit
container that blocks the startup of
your new parts until the migration is
done and then as part of your deployment
you can deploy a job that will perform
the migration so your rolling update
would wait on that migration to be
performed by a job to do schedule and
then those init containers will unblock
the further starting of all the new pods
so you can also do that via Helm hooks
so if you just have an upgrade that will
automatically schedule that job for you
yeah if you use hand weight it would
wait try to wait for all the pots to
start up for scheduling the job you do
not want that in that instance
yeah that's how you configure a help
hook you just set some annotations and
we'll recognize these
so the way I did this I have an init
container
uh in every important part that needs a
database that just runs some tool image
with the command to wait for the
database
also a tip for me from my side Implement
consistent versioning
make sure that your pipeline runs have
the same version as your containers as a
Helm chart
I really like to use noteband git
versioning here it's a tool called.net
nbgv that just makes some environment
variables based available based on your
git history
and then I can just update him charts
publish them Etc
also note you can use kubernetes in your
application as well so
um
those parts will usually be scheduled
using a service account and you can give
this service account right to do
something like read configuration
scheduled jobs update deployments and
you can use the kubernetes client nougat
package to actually do that so
the way the smokes is you can at some
point specify a service account
and make sure that this service account
makes the token available to each
container
you do find some rights on some specific
apis
using rows and role bindings yeah it's a
topic that could fill an hour as well
and then in the art.net code you can use
HTTP clients
typed HTTP clients using the HTTP client
Factory to create new kubernetes client
instances
and in this case we were writing some
implementing partitioning for a service
where we found out yeah we have some
problems with cap theorem let's work
around that
so we were watching all the other
services that were started and you
figure out which requests to send to
which individual part so we are using
services to resolve all the instances
that are running behind the service
but you can do much more
some other things you can look into Auto
scaling
you can do that via something called
horizontal Port autoscaler which is very
dumb thing that just looks at high CPU
usage or event Driven Auto scaling
things that would look at like your cue
length you can also use service meshes
that help you with securing
Communications between services and also
having some policies to say which thing
can talk to each other thing
again monitoring tracing tools there are
two great projects one is Dapper due to
distributed application runtime
that helps you that also gives you more
abstractions you can be using
distributed applications also if you
don't like to create yaml files while
developing something this project tie
that's basically like a compose file
for kubernetes
and one more topic you can also explore
you're already running in this system
that is basically a database
maybe you want to use your own resource
type so things like deployment service
Etc I could have like machine
configuration
and I would no longer have to implement
something like a contract system for
that I could just load machine
configurations by the kubernetes API
um that works I won't specify a schema
tell kubernetes hey expect objects with
that schema and then I could write in
operator
that basically looks at this at these
definitions and does something based on
that maybe scheduled instances of
deployments
or do some configuration changes based
on that
and that would work with all the uis
so it would show up in for example that
Ranger I showed you and you could use
that for example as a configuration
interface
so since there is no time left for
questions
just talk to me and have fun at the
conference
thank you
[Applause]